this is a tragic death one of the
participants in a Dutch study the 18
year old trans identified male whose
puberty was blocked by the Dutch
researchers at a very early stage
meaning there wasn't enough penile
tissue for surgeons to use to create the
new Vagina therefore a more risky
procedure using a section of the
patient's bowel was necessary
which resulted in necrotizing fasciitis
now I guess in a few years are going to
be better at this isn't that the hope I
do not want my son's [__] infected and
I want better [__] for the ladies but
you want them to be healthy and happy
and have the best private parts they can
have that can't be controversial it
can't be controversial to say I want my
transgender son or daughter to have the
best fake private parts they can have
and I'll pay for it I've got money I've
got money to buy a [__] for my daughter
but it's got to be good it can't kill
her
your [__] killed my son